[Music]
in times of crisis
you can trust sports to do its bit
and even though football can be tribal
today there was a coming together
fans and players draped in yellow and
blue to stand with ukraine and its
people
but the emotion for man city's alexander
zinchenko and everton's vitali mikalenko
was too raw
emotions 2 at chelsea as the club's
billionaire russian owner roman
abramovich following increased pressure
announced he's giving up stewardship of
the club
in a statement he said i have always
taken decisions with the club's best
interest at heart i remain committed to
these values that is why i am today
giving trustees of chelsea's charitable
foundation the stewardship and care of
chelsea fc
it's believed after almost 20 years this
means mr abramovic is taking a step back
no longer involved in day-to-day club
business but it's not clear how long for
i think roman abramovich will have taken
legal advice and will have been
concerned that potentially chelsea
football club could have been seized
from him and transferred effectively to
the british government he didn't want
that so by going through these
particular steps i think he's trying to
protect both the football club but more
importantly himself
already russia has lost playing host to
the champions league final its f1 grand
prix in sochi has been axed and today
poland and sweden declared they'll
refuse to play their russian
counterparts in playoffs for this year's
world cup some believe they shouldn't be
allowed to be there at all
they are not very happy with that those
decisions of course and thought that
sports and football should not be linked
with politics but that's exactly how
russia has been using sports in the past
so
i think it's good to see that the sports
are also showing that they have
their own opinion and as i said before
that human rights are more important
than finances
but today was about support for ukraine
fans in bradford clapping in solidarity
an aston villa player supporting his
teammate currently in kiev
and a top flight club pleading for peace
on the global stage
as russia is punished it is ukraine that
still suffers
that is the bigger picture
football today united in its desire for
peace
played a small part in saman rashid sky
news